Jad. Yeah. Let me play you this. Mm Buddy. Yes, ma'am.
You're listening to Mike Nichols. I've been thinking, and Elaine May,
you're getting old and now you're nearly a man and you should start thinking
about your future a little bit.
You know you're listening to like her soul that happened to get caught on tape.
You're happy with
30 gods.
He has a joke in his head. I know what I'd like to do with my life.
He just can't punchline out without ruining it.
There's all that you have to train for some years. What is the JV?
Here's a general or you haven't heard it yet
and wants to be when he grows up, you're ready.
He registered nurse. The joke is, I want to be a nurse.
I wanted to be a nurse so he can't say the word without worry about losing.
She say the word nurse. That is their punchline.
And why is that funny?
You will remember it's 1959 and boys don't want to be registered nurses.
Not In 1959 from Mike Nichols. The funniest thing he thought of all week.
Not Funny, but he can't,
which was but a mother.
I want very much to be a registered.
Yes. I love this. We heard so I don't know why I could listen to this.
150 listen to an now 50 times.
I want very much to be a registered nurse.
So no, go on that one. Understand this.
Laughter just keeps bubbling up. Mike can't control it.
Ilene can people here.
Here's the thing.
These are two of the greatest humorist of the mid 20th century.
The United States, they're professional improvisational comics.
They lived to laugh. They control if they try to create laugh,
they're all about laughter and yet left to mix them.
Here we are the species with the capacity for language,
which allows us exquisitely nuanced expressions. This is Tyler Stillman.
He studies laughter at Florida State University and yet we produce these kinds
of bizarre Sam.
No laughter is this kind of clumsy in articulate way of expressing ourselves,
but it's also kind of awesome.
Yeah,
so looking forward is the question then. Why is laughter so awesome? Highways,
I hate that word. Awesome, but I will say that it's a good question to ask.
Why do we laugh? What is laughter for and why those sounds,
why those sounds. All right. Well let's go. Our topic today is laughter.
I'm Jad Abumrad hi, I'm Robert Krulwich, Radiolab.
[inaudible].
Okay, so to get started, that thing we just talked about,
the weirdness of laughter.
Now how it's both like I'm clumsy on one hand,
but also kind of awesome. Yeah, I know you love that word. Awesome.
I'll see why you have to see that word all the way delightful.
Delightful is a great, delightful.
What do I really want to say is that that sort of paradox is something that some
of the greatest minds in history have thought about and written about.
Like Aristotle
in a book called De Unimog. Liam.
Aristotle wants to describe what separates human beings out from all the other
creatures.
That's historian. Very Sandra's.
He wrote a book about laughter called Settin Gloria, and according to him,
after pages and pages of complicated reasoning about what makes us special.
Is it language? Is it reason? Is it this? Is it that?
Aristotle concludes one thing. What?
What makes us absolutely different is our capacity to laugh. When you laugh,
go ahead and do it. [inaudible]
that right there. Okay. That is a specifically human endeavor.
No other creatures can do it. Not only that, the first time you do it,
you mean like when you're a little paper and you're doing your tiny baby and you
make your first left.
That to Aristotle might be the most important moment of your life because it's
the moment that your life, at least as a human being begins.
When the infant utters its first left, emits its first left.
At that moment,
heated air from lower in the stomach moves through a membrane into the soul in
souls
[inaudible]
and at that point then this is the fine distinction. At that point,
the creature moves from being a human into a human being.
Yes, yes. He's absolutely, I remember it so clearly. The symbols,
the clashes, I think, oh, I'm a human being, but, but, but,
but do you remember when it happened? No. Yeah.
Well Aristotle was very specific about this.
He thought it always happened or should happen on the 40th day of your
existence.
Oh, okay.
[inaudible] today is your 40th day.
We wanted to check this proposition.
So we called up radio producer Amanda Aronchick who just had a brand new baby
girl.
Nina is celebrating her 40th day of existence today.
We're going to get you to laugh now.
Were you able to record with Mina this morning? You're ready for that? Oh yeah.
Oh yeah. No, we recorded for 50 minutes. Really? We just like went for it.
And did she laugh? Well I tried pretty rob tried. Hmm.
Or aunt tried a laugh. I went almost ugly.
We all tried and tried to kind of harass her and like stick your tongue out
editor and try to tickle her and, and then at the end she's like
[inaudible]
we have yet to get a kick out of her. I need to smile.
You laugh.
But you made some sounds we've never ever heard before.
[inaudible]
like her level of interaction in the last two days has been more than anything
we've seen. Really. Like, if you stick your tongue out at her, she does it back.
And if you open your mouth, she kind of tries to do that too.
That has been a milestone, you know, aside from the actual day count,
like it really is. She's becoming a little beanie.
It's, it's much more emotional.
It's like you're looking at this thing that you're deeply in love with and it's
finally like looking back at you.
Well, Romanda when it happens, will you call us right back? Okay.
I will for sure.
Oh,
do you agree with Aristotle that,
that this is the ability to laugh is what literally separates us from the rest
of the animal kingdom? God, how can I disagree with Aristotle? That would be,
you know, blessing has been not as a negative. I mean, you as a person,
as a person. Um, I, I w I,
I truly believe we're the only creature that laughs.
What about you? I,
I do think there's something about the way we laugh,
the way we share, uh, the emotional feeling that leads to laugh.
That is kind of, I don't know of any other creatures that do that.
Um, you can't do that to me. I don't know if we're,
I don't know if it's wrong because in truth, in all honesty, this,
this scientific debate is still, uh,
the jury is still out on this question whether we are the only ones that laugh,
but it's one of those things that if you poke around a bit and let's poke,
shall we? Okay. Guide you. The question becomes much more common.
Oh, okay. So, uh, introduce yourself so I don't,
I don't mangle your name too badly. Oh, absolutely. Uh,
my name is Jaak Panksepp. Jaak Panksepp. Yes. Yuck.
Panksepp is in neuroscientists, Washington State University,
and for the last 30 years he has studied animal emotion particularly.
And this is his specialty happiness and play play playfulness in rats,
for example, to do duets play. Oh yeah. Oh yes.
When they're still young and you put them together,
they start tussling immediately.
Well, when they play, they're silent. I mean, no,
we've got no squeaks or anything.
[inaudible] all the while their head butting each other or they're flipping each
other over. They play really hard. No sounds. That's our starting point. Okay.
So one day Jaak Undergrad students are standing in front of a rat cage washing
two rats wrestle silently. And the Grad students,
guy by the name of Brian Turns to you, I can says, is it really possible?
They're not making any noises. I mean, look at them.
Maybe they're making sounds, but we just can't them. Uh,
so he suggested to [inaudible],
why don't we order one of these little black boxes?
They call them back detectors and nature. People used to listen to bats.
What if we put one on the rat cage?
Maybe it will take whatever sounds might or might not be there,
lower them down to a range that humans can hear that. I said, okay,
well buy the equipment and the equipment arrived.
And the first day we had a couple of animals playing and we tuned it through the
various frequencies and lo and behold,
it's like our playground f 50 killer.
What did it sound like? It's like,
could you, did you [inaudible]
so all of a sudden you just heard this sound erupt from the little box? Yeah,
absolutely. Absolutely. Wow.
So now they had the sound that no one had ever heard before and there's two
things you need to know. First, the rats would make the sound sporadically.
Each villa rap would make it just like the chicken chip chip and second,
y'all had no idea what the sound was. What did it mean? What does it mean?
What does it, what are they saying? What are they saying to each other?
You knew had something to do with play, but was it just like a, hi, hi, hi.
Or was it something more aggressive? Like you want a piece of me,
let's wrestle best one. I think. Or maybe they're excited and they're saying,
give me sex. You want to have sex and get rallied.
You make couple of chirps and maybe it was just a grunt of some sort.
There's a lot of possibilities. 10 years, 10 years.
They study this sound trying to figure out what it means and every theory failed
somehow. Well, nothing was conclusive. [inaudible].
Then one morning yuck walks in to the lab,
which she showed us her going to the animal facility on the fifth floor with a
crazy idea. One morning I came in and says, Jeff is Grad student at the time.
Jeff, let's go tickle some rats.
What on Earth gave you that idea? I don't know.
This is the mystery of having a new idea. Oh, okay.
So he and his Grad student quickly walk over to the rat cage, pick up our rent,
and we carry it to a box. We put it in the box. Yeah. Okay.
And the animals going in and I began to tickle it. Am I tickle?
It's just like you. You would tickle a baby. Meaning what? Like could you,
could you, could you cool with the fingers?
You're moving your fingers rapidly all over the animal's body or some male rant.
He demonstrated tickle
sound. The chemo is the same as before,
but now it was louder. More continuous. You can see how consistent it is.
Plus it had this very familiar rhythm and familiar dynamic quality.
The way it went
in for the first time it occurred to Yuck. I'm like, God,
what if that's left there?
What if that sound is laughter and visually?
I'm going to say it's pretty convincing when you see him do it.
When you put a video on a website, radiolab.org when you see him,
particular rat and the rat kick its little rat legs and Chirp like mad.
It does look at the animals cracking up like a little kid. Yeah.
Oh, oh,
oh, oh.
To where you're thinking at this moment we were thinking this a fluke.
It's a fluke. This will float. See it and trust what you were hearing. Oh,
well we trust what we're hearing, but I said, let me get another animal.
Here's another rent. Ready for a tickle session. Tickle.
Whoa. Syngo exactly the same. [inaudible]. Exactly.
I still kind of said, come on. This is too good to be true.
Let me get another animal. You tickle
exactly the same chat. Here's the kicker.
The moment Jaak stops tickling the rats moves his hand away.
The rat starts chasing his hand and moves his hand left. The rat goes, left,
moves to the hand, right. The rat goes, right, exactly.
The animal does glued to your hand because it wants to be tickled again at once
more. Exactly. So cool. Whoa. Hello.
I'm just running circles with my hand and the animals running circles right
after my fingers. Once some more. Ho Ho. Okay.
And if you stop tickling and you just leave your hand there in the cage,
like a dead piece of meat [inaudible] the animal knows you're alive and
gradually it begins to pounce on your head and it begins to nitpick your face.
It's like, c'mon. C'Mon. Exactly.
Let me ask you this though, in terms of calling me the squeaking,
a squeak or a Chirp or a chip or whenever you want to call it,
that would be one thing,
but to call it laughter is saying something very specific. Yeah.
Yeah. A lot of people don't like that word. Huh? Oh.
Even my friends have advised me to drop that word because they don't think that
a rat can feel joy or is that, is that,
is that what giving human qualities to animals has been unknown? No.
Since we are closer to the angels than the other creatures in the world.
[inaudible]
AH, two laughs. Two feeling. He was kidding by the way.
Oh really? Oh. Oh. I kind of believed him. Oh, you think that he was being,
I thought he meant the laughter in the subtle way that he imagined. No, no, no,
no. He thinks human laughter is not special. He thinks the Aristotle's wrong.
Basically. Check it out. Aristotle do an experiment.
Like it goes back a long way. Back to rats. Pigeons. Who knows?
And that all these creatures
laugh like us and they laugh more or less for the same reason as us.
Hmm. I don't know.
Utila pigeon a good chicken crushing the old joke and you're going to get
nothing. Why? What do you don't think that a pigeon has a rich emotional life?
No. Joy. No. I have taught with pigeons. Let me tell you something. All right.
I'll give it that. We probably left for irony. Yeah, we, we'd probably do that.
And I'd like you think legend last for delight. I don't know. But sure.
A pigeon experiences delight, but don't even know you're not a pigeon.
You forget the pigeon. I'm a kid. Oh, take a bird that sings. I bet.
I bet birds sing because they're happy and singing is probably in a way like
laughing. Oh, if you're going to get all general, I'm the, yeah.
Where it was like the wiggle and wiggling. It's Kinda like
why would my day, what's happened to the bay to Baby Amanda Humane?
When did she laugh yet? Yeah. Uh, no, actually not.
Oh, see, so Aristotle's really in deep doodoo here. I mean these days,
I don't know about ancient Greece, but these days,
people who study this stuff say it's usually around 90 days is what is the
general time [inaudible] the time. So I told her to call us back when,
when she does laugh.
Message One, hey there dad,
it's Amanda Roger Calling and I am calling to say that Nina just laughed.
She just laughed. She actually full on did a life. Ha ha ha.
Like that. Um, there was incredibly exciting. Um,
but it was not day 40. It was day by my calculations in 97. So,
uh, I don't know about Aristotle and those babies, but um,
this baby here left for real,
definitely 100% on day 97.
So it's very exciting and we're very excited and now she's crying because there
was so much effort to laugh, I think. Um, okay.
And this message
now for the next question, forgetting for a moment how we laugh.
Let's ask why we laugh and I'll tell you why we laugh. Why do we laugh?
We laugh cause something's funny. No, no, no, no.
The most important thing to remember about laughter is that it's social and it's
not about humor. That's Robert Pro,
Vine and euro scientists at the University of Maryland who got very interested
in this question.
So he went out on the street with some of his Grad students pen in hand,
and they listened. Well,
what people actually in real life say just before they laugh and in 85% of the
cases are you writing this now? Is he 5% of the cases? Nothing funny.
Proceeded the lab. Yeah. So first of all,
people weren't really telling jokes to other people.
They were saying things like, Hey, what are you being on? I've got to go now.
I have a class, I have a class.
[inaudible] this is the kind of things that people say before they life.
Now don't take my word for this. Got Cocktail Party.
You're going to be a lot of laughter there,
but people are not telling jokes to each other to furious. Right?
So laughter isn't about joking. It's about something else.
It's about social relationships. You gotta have those people there.
When you're alone. Laughter basically disappears
when you're at home along Jad. Do you never find yourself laughing?
[inaudible] hell yeah. Well, you see sometimes when,
like when I'm watching the TV or something like that,
kind of vicarious social stimulus. I mean like when you are solitary,
if you take away media, no radio, no TV, no nothing in your ears,
no laughter basically disappears. So we have an unconsciously controlled,
neurologically programmed social behavior that will only work if there's a
sharer,
even if the share is just in your head and neurologic neurologically programmed
by who? By M evolution. In this case. Towards the end of the interview,
he walked me over to his a TV VCR thing. He has state of the art stuff.
This is pretty fancy, and he showed me a video of a woman tickling a chimpanzee.
What is this? I have an example here of laughter from our primate ancestors.
They be chimps.
Okay?
We have now a chimpanzee on the screen and you're listening to a chimpanzee
playing with a, a a woman. If you get a game going, that's the woman laughing.
She is now puddling and smothering the chimp with cogs
and he's being tickled.
That's chimpanzee laughter at panning sound. Do you hear
chimpanzee laughter? The low level of chimpanzee panting laugh too.
It'd be like [inaudible].
Okay.
When they really get into it, it becomes more guttural like
sound
pro things. It has nothing to do with jokes.
This is not a reaction to any other. Tickling is kind of delightful [inaudible],
but what it really is doing,
he says that particular sound is a signal. One chimp to the other,
and those two chimps to any other animals that happened to come by.
Other chimps. We're just playing. Shims have evolved.
It's taken them a long time, but they figured out a way to signal,
we're not fighting. I'm not going to kill you. This is just play.
It's the signal of we're just,
I to get into it, it becomes more aggressive. Safe.
According to pro vine, we inherited that signal from our chimp relatives. Yeah.
So basically panting became, Haha.
Oh, in a human.
We've just added one little wonderful extra.
The H.